reason nasu lula da silva was leading
the polls in 2018.
the left-wing political leader would
have probably been elected brazil's
president
for the third time had he not been
convicted
on corruption charges and banned from
running
now lula is back in the political scene
as the country faces
its worst moment in the covet 19
pandemic
and he poses a serious threat to
right-wing president
jair bolsonaro in next year's elections
it's good news that comes at the right
time because the political situation in
the country is so dire
i would not believe a politician who has
already been arrested for corruption
and i don't think lula is the right
person to run our country
lula has always said that he was wrongly
convicted and imprisoned
he says the bribery money laundering and
corruption charges
were part of a scheme to strip him of
his political rights
after years of judicial battle a supreme
court judge on monday
annulled the convictions against lula
the decision has nothing to do with
lula's innocence or guilt
the supreme court judge argued that the
former president had been tried in the
southern city of kurichiba
when he should have been tried in the
capital brasilia
it may be a technicality but one that
could be shaped
brazil's political and judicial
landscape
the fact is that lula can now run for
the presidency
and he still has the support of half of
brazil's voters
according to a recent poll some of them
took to the streets to celebrate
and to protest against what they call
president bolsonaro's mishandling of the
pandemic
lula reacted on twitter saying the
annulment of the charges
proves he has always been right while
bolsonaro accused the supreme court
judge
of acting on behalf of the workers party
brazil's political divisions deepening
in the midst of a deadly pandemic
monika yanakiv al-jazeera rio de janeiro